hachimachi that middle class famous tour
is in full swing gipperino you ain't
lying fatty it's a live comedy show we
play a little ayg with the crowd great
way to introduce people to the show
bring the squad come out and see us
we're coming baby yeah gang these
tickets are selling quickly uh so make
sure you get your tickets we're coming
in we're going to be red bank new jersey
then we're going to seattle portland all
in august then in september we're going
kansas city springfield st louis then
we're going down to nashville hitting
indy coming home to philly baby the
chicken's got to come home to roost yeah
then we're hitting providence rhode
island up there to bean town get those
tickets let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians that
we find out they grow to be classy or
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host states foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antodi's basement she's over there at
the wawa okay getting a couple
scratchers coming back to the house with
an arrow so iced tea okay she's having a
quiet time today mike cohost is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
ceo of ru garbage he is an international
businessman he is the prince of park
avenue but always the king of the boards
baby give it up for kj kevin james ryan
hey gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube as you know those numbers are
true
cooking and then the greatest website of
all time
www.patreon.com you can sign up there
join the [ __ ] army of garbage we
appreciate you sweet lord we love that
money how about a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good he crosses
the t's and dots the eyes he works the
ones and twos give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen everybody what's
up dudes what's up t-bone dude
we got a [ __ ] legend
one baby gang the long hair ain't lying
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and i mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time he is a legendary comedian actor
broadcaster and now author you've seen
him in but not limited to get ready for
this rap sheet put a cup of coffee on
jesus christ you've seen him down to you
mad tv frank mccluskey ci son of the
beach windy city heat the bernie mac
show wasted family guy the hammer which
he also co-wrote and starred in
fantastic movie
drawn together
you got the sarah silverman program
wizards of waverly place still waiting
wreck-it ralph crank yankers politically
incorrect hollywood squares love line
wynne ben stein's money hannity guys
miller
[Laughter]
howard stern craig kilbourne david
letterman oprah ever heard of her live
with kelly and ryan dancing with the
stars jay leno the soup wtf rachel ray
the apprentice the tonight show the joe
rogan experience hot ones hell's kitchen
gut felled and of course you can hear
him every week on the adam and drew show
the adam carolla show and unreasonable
doubt and he's the proud author of the
brand new book which you could get at
adamkarall.com entitled everything
reminds me of something advice answers
but no apologies but the big question
with his mind today is he garbage i
think he's mad at us
give it up for adam carol everybody
hello thank you thanks for coming buddy
thanks for having me yeah what do you
mean buddy thank you so much for coming
in good to see you give us the back
story what's the what's the origin story
of adam corolla uh i grew up in uh north
hollywood california which is okay
you know suburb of los angeles san
fernando valley
grew up sort of poor essentially i mean
my mom was a food stamps and welfare my
dad worked as a substitute school
teacher lived in a little little
one-bedroom one-bed bathroom house it
was my
grandmother's she bought it for rental
property but okay i do want to say this
if you're and i don't know if you guys
are parents but i will say this
if you're thinking about buying a second
house as a rental property but then you
wreck your daughter she's gonna live in
it for free yeah yeah yeah so
i lose out on some income business model
is don't have kids and buy a second
rental or do have kids and nurture them
and buy a second and say do not ruin
your daughter she will squat there for
the rest of your natural life with her
loser family
and you will get zero in rent and she
will resent you sure sure holy [ __ ] how
many brothers and sisters have one
sister that's a one year older one year
older okay
the parents were together the whole time
no they were together until i was about
eight okay or so and then they just sort
of they didn't divorce they just moved
apart because they didn't have
belongings yeah yeah and you just leave
kind of when you get divorced and
there's nothing to argue over you know i
was like you know that's my throw pillow
i'm taking this toaster god damn it
yeah that's you can leave but leave the
hubcaps yeah if there's nothing to whack
up you just just move out that's what
they did that's a very old school thing
too
getting separated but never getting
divorced yeah there wasn't they both got
remarried later on in life but initially
it would have been some filings or
courts or
cost someone 18 to file it or something
that [ __ ] notarized it wasn't wasn't
worth it they didn't have anything very
nice so nobody lives there now right
uh well my my mom
that house was uh sold and then
demolished so they the land was worth
more than the house even though it's
in the middle of north hollywood like
studio city valley village there's not
too many tear downs there but uh this
was a tear down okay and then she then
moved into her mom's primary house after
her mom died so not only did she live in
her rental property but then she waited
for her to die and then she moved into
the main house but still one bedroom one
bath so there wasn't
that big of a man kind of a lateral move
bart but uh yeah she's been living in
mama's houses very nice what was the
name of the street that the original
house was on houston with a
u-h-u-s-t-o-n okay north hollywood not
too bad any pets or anything growing up
we had a cat that just sort of let
itself in like kind of a stray cat you
know just showed up one day well we had
uh we had one wall mount air conditioner
because the house was like 100 years old
so we didn't have central heat or air
but we had the one wall mount which was
in
the den where the one tv was and it
had the uh
the window mount the kind of stuff in
the window sure and then because you
know not all windows are the same width
they have this weird accordion thing on
the side yeah yeah you can suck it off
and so we pull the accordion out but
eventually the plastic gets old and
weathered and of course heat cycles a
few times eventually
one of the pieces of plastic accordion
bloat blew out so then there was just
daylight
so my mom
uh took a jean leg a leg from a cut off
jeans you know cause you know that's
still good denim
why put that in the landfill there's you
know there's 18 cents worth of denim and
she took two pushpins and she put it up
in the gap where the accordion was and
then at some point a cat showed up
and that was uh norman the cat and he
just hung out and that was sort of his
doggy door he just come in and hang out
you know and then go back out through
the flap again you guys would feed him i
assume yeah he just became this became
our cat dude that's [ __ ] wild geez
what was the name of the grocery store
that you went to growing up
well there was there was
lucky's which was the the cheap one and
then then there was gelsen's which was
the nice one you know so
lucky's we would go to to shop
but gelsons i would go to because they
had a deli counter in the back you know
and you didn't have to pay
until you got to the front oh boy and so
i would go there he's in the back making
the same we had whole turkey legs
big old whole drumstick turkey legs and
i'd get one of those and then you know
put it in the foil bag and stuff and
then i'd wander around for what i
thought was a sufficient amount of time
and and then i'd just kind of stroll you
know in through the outdoor kind of kind
of thing and then just go eat the turkey
legs like you're at medieval times no
that's why yeah mine is the tournament
or maybe the tournament was me evading
the police that was the show that day
shop at lucky's and you'd steal at
gilson's
pretty much
yeah at the end of the day i respect
he's not gonna steal cheap [ __ ] you know
what i mean yeah gelson's was
more expensive and that was a higher end
place but you couldn't really shop there
and where do you food shop now
i guess
when i do it's like trader joe's or
something okay like that and do you live
out and you live out in l.a now yeah
gotcha all right on the coast we'll get
to that a little bit i like to see that
uh growing up would you drink milk with
dinner
no i didn't i didn't like milk when i
was uh when i was a kid so we didn't
drink milk with dinner we i don't think
we drank anything with dinner with this
drink
stared at the white some humble pie wash
it down with some tap water
sometimes we'd break it up and eat crow
you know yeah just whatever whatever
negativity there was to eat what uh
would your mom was your mom a good cook
no no well i don't know she never cooked
yeah she could have been a michelin
rated chef for all we know nobody knew
what would be a typical dinner what
would she make uh well my mom was
kind of into hippy dippy kind of health
food times you know 70s and all okay and
so she didn't you know she wasn't down
with red meat or meat or all that so
she would make like a lentil s soup that
had you know like a meatless lentil soup
you know or something weird and then at
a certain point
uh we just transitioned to tv dinners
because like all right it's too much
yeah
the food was so shitty tasting and
nobody liked it and no one wanted to eat
lentil at any age really but especially
at 14 or 9 or 11 it's not fun it's not
there's no lentil sandwich there's no
lentil casserole it's it's bad stuff so
uh at some point i guess she would just
buy tv dinners we just do tv dinners man
like all right what would you do on like
thanksgiving and stuff
thanksgiving we'd go to my grandparents
house who would do up something for
thanksgiving and or later on maybe just
go out somewhere to a restaurant or
something yeah like my grandparents were
like sort of normal and i guess we'd go
out too like did they do okay did they
do somewhat well your grandparents or if
they had a rental property theoretically
well they they did they but they they
had one rental that they bought for ten
thousand dollars in like 1952. that's
the one we grew up in gotcha and then
they had their
house which is another like twelve
thousand dollar purchase from like 49 or
something so they bought these two
one bedroom one bath you know no central
air no central heat you know 900 square
foot kind of valley boxes but my
grandmother worked for the va okay all
the time so she had a job you know as a
va jobs at government good bennies yeah
and my grandfather
who's my step-grandfather's not my
biological grandfather
uh
he this on my mom's side uh he was a
retired writer so he wrote he wrote he
wrote his eyesight got bad and sort of
became a stay-at-home husband okay she
went to
uh the the good
she she became the breadwinner you know
she went out
and earned the money he stayed home and
just sort of cooked and cleaned okay and
then my dad's side his parents were from
philly and they
his mom was old's dad died when he was
young they didn't have any money so no
there was no did you see your dad a lot
growing up
yeah we split uh in between
my dad's place and my mom's place my dad
got a
one-bedroom apartment just in north
hollywood this you know a couple miles
away and they're really into the one
bedroom yeah i know
he was so i hope your house now has a
thousand bedrooms just just despite all
the missing bedrooms i do have i have my
present wrapping gr good good you
deserve it the the uh he didn't have any
money when they broke up so he he moved
in and lived in a like a large closet in
my grandparents house because he didn't
have money
that was his
that was a woman and he moved into his
shoes the woman he left he moved into
her parents house with them
essentially okay in his 40s
so he didn't have money
and uh then he saved some money and he
got an apartment and that's
that's where so then
she had the
one small house he had the one small
apartment just sort of go back go back
and forth yeah his place on the weekends
uh it wasn't
you know it's that it's not like people
were fighting over us you know
if there was a fight it'd be like i've
had him two days in a row why can't you
take it you know
why do i have to do another lent a pot
of lentil stew get this goddamn cat out
of here yeah they were just we'd kind of
catch his catch can maybe you know i
don't know monday wednesday friday with
the thing and they they didn't need
their weekends
it wasn't they weren't up to anything
we're not partying or anything now yeah
and how were you in school did you do
good in school no
no i didn't do well i was uh i didn't
have i i didn't learn to read or write
like you know early
in my whatever those formative years are
what's early what are we talking about
here whenever you're supposed to you
know whatever that is what did you learn
to read now oh when yeah you know
ostensibly when i got into show business
like really yeah what are you sling
blade what does yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah you wrote a tribe you're
writing a book
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
well you know i i went
i missed out on
traditional school from
zero to
about
the fifth grade is when i was when i
entered like a conventional is this
because the mom was hippie-ish yeah my
mom was hippie-ish and so it was kind of
like hang back free to be you and me
kind of communal like went to school in
the house i would have never pegged you
for any of this nothing well my dad was
from philly and
you know sort of straight you know
normal or whatever my mom was kind of
california hippie
and
so we ended up in this
community school like you know someone's
house and silver lake and we just
threw dirt clods and made stuff out of
clay you know we didn't there was no
learning there was no books there's no
anything
then at some point that just kind of all
dried up and uh i ended up just going
across the street to colfax elementary
it was just a regular your mom put you
in school
yeah
she put me in the one i could walk to
you know and and so i entered in the
fifth grade
and i didn't know i don't know anything
you know i was like crocodile dundee
i didn't know i i i mean it like the you
know the bell would ring and people
would start moving i'd be like is there
a fire they'd be like no that's the bell
when can we make stuff out of clay and
then the kid like i remember a kid just
looking at me because the bell was
ringing and i was just like looking
around going what is the significance of
this this means something i gotta figure
it out and he started walking and he
said
you're gonna be tardy and i said what
the [ __ ] tardy me i don't know what
that word is no one uses tardy outside
of school
i've never heard tardy
he could have said late yeah
that kid was a [ __ ] nerd i'll tell
you that right now so i i just kind of
like showed up and i couldn't read or
write and i was just kind of
you know um so i just kind of sat in the
back of the class and just kind of kept
my head down you know and uh that that
was it for me like i
i just couldn't do any of the work i you
know but i pretended to read you know
like if somebody
you know if somebody showed me a funny
note or something like that and said
look at this i'd i'd look at it for the
amount of time i thought a person
would take to read it and then i'd go oh
yeah that's good that's a good one
that's like lying about seeing a movie
yeah that was a good one yeah i wish i
needed glasses because i would have
broke them shoved them in my pocket and
went ah sorry man but i just kind of
faked my way you know through it that's
amazing that's [ __ ] why you couldn't
read anything i couldn't i couldn't read
at well and that carried into six seven
you know it just kept going you don't
stop at fifth
it's not like that guy was a racist in
the fifth grade
and he grew up he kept it going
so what were the sats like did you take
them no yeah no no that would have been
did you graduate high school
yeah i graduated on uh i found out the
last day that i graduated i had to pass
i failed biology and i failed driver's
head though yeah you couldn't read what
the [ __ ] no i know it was it was a
disaster but i
i
well i i actually so
i the day before graduation
i took uh i i got a d in my spanish you
know final or whatever just cheated off
of somebody and there you go and they
let me participate but i never got my my
diploma because i owed the book room
money for books they were
you know it was like it was like 1895
for we the people and i was like
no way yeah no way
i don't have 20 bucks laying around and
i know i'm not going to need this
piece of paper this piece of parchment
and and i never did i you know i
technically graduated i never got my
diploma and i just walked
basically on a construction site yeah
that was it were you drinking what was
the social life like in
high school was that hindered in high
school in junior high
i was i was uh a jock and i was good at
football i was good at baseball
so dr drew said you were making fun of
him i kind of kind of had that going for
me i wasn't really much of a partier i
wasn't
you know i wasn't a troublemaker i was
just kind of kept my head down played
football okay
like sports or good at something i
played linebacker and guard as well on
the offensive side and i was good like i
got all valley and
you know
some scholarships but
i couldn't read so i was like i i
i could have maybe
even alabama wouldn't take it i i was
not being recruited by alabama i was you
know uc davis or cal poly pomona holy
[ __ ] yeah it's wild man marshall
actually really there you go yeah but
that was
you know
a short period of time after the plane
crashed
they needed
human beings
we just got cleaned out yeah yeah
yeah that was probably i didn't know it
at the time but i was like
i was like marshall's a decent program
what are they doing i've seen them in
the news i think yeah ganger brought to
you by adamandeve.com
kippy like to experiment in the bedroom
with a couple of toys let's get freaky
talking about no gi joes either nope i
bring those puppies and that's my
clothes anal beads butt plugs
don't tell my wife
guys go to adamandeve.com do yourself a
favor gang whether you're spending time
by yourself having a good time or you
gotta you got a partner in the room or a
couple whatever you're into it's 2022
let's have a little [ __ ] fun year a
little bit of hanky-panky that's what
i'm talking about pick yourself up some
products over there at adam and eve what
is it fifty percent off what the [ __ ]
plus free shipping with code garbage
adamandeve.com 50 off uh plus free
shipping with promo code garbage
you need a penis pump it's that time of
the year you know what i mean
i got one on me it's not my bag baby
uh i need the works blow up dolls it
won't blow up your wallet
huh what are you gonna take it to dinner
that's just gonna happen when you die
i'm gonna replace you with a blow-up
doll
wet my beak a little bit yeah i bet you
will finally get the heavens get the
makeup to you uh just use promo code
garbage to check how you get 50 off and
free shipping we said it once we said it
a thousand times all packages are
discreet aunt cody won't be finding out
about this one
not only deliveries oh yeah not only we
save money on gas movies date night out
adam and eve will continue to save money
and deliver tons of fun go to
adamandeve.com select any one item use
promo code garbage
uh this is exclusive offer for our
listeners make sure you use promo promo
code garbage do it do it can't let's
talk about butcher box butcher box come
on you know them you love them
what do you like doing you like going to
the grocery store and getting a bunch of
chicken pumpful with antibiotics huh you
like a little d-ball in your [ __ ]
chicken breasts or do you like
free-range wild-caught grass-fed
grass-finished fantastic product meat
ship right to your door you throw it in
the freezer when you're ready to start
grilling take it out frost it slap it on
there boom it's grilling season baby
don't look like a bozo out there making
sure you got the best [ __ ] on the market
that's hot graphite free range organic
chicken while concentrating food no
antibiotics no hormones pack fresh right
to your door uh delicious 100
all the time grass fed unbeatable value
less than six dollars per meal like
we've said a hundred times
the good folks over there put your box
send it to us my fridge is still full i
use it we me and the lady just pulled
out some steaks the other day and i made
them on a cast iron pan with the butter
and a garlic and the rosemary too
much what's the turkey what are they
giving away this month a whole bull
something crazy like that uh why would
you ask something so stupid when you
know it's free bacon for life for the
cheese the life of your membership plus
ten dollars off get summer sizzling
started with the special offer from
butcher box for our listeners sign up
today at putrebox.comyg
use code ayg to get one pack of free
bacon in every box for the life of your
membership plus ten dollars off your
first order that's butcherbox.com ayg
use code ayg to claim this deal
do it
what was the first concert you went to
um i believe
i saw the cars with a friend of mine
that's pretty legit who had a car so it
was like
he could buy the tickets he was like a
or two older than me you know he bought
tickets
and he had a car it was probably like in
the 11th grade or something and we saw
the cars not bad that's a [ __ ] good
one anybody involved in a class action
lawsuit growing up uh
no but we we
it wasn't all the rage back then like
now it's like did you work in the ship
building industry did your priest
probably last year yeah yeah now it's
come out yeah now it's all coming out
when i was sitting home we weren't
watching commercials for class-action
lawsuits we were watching commercials
for truck driving schools right that's
the way people
who were losers got paid
i had to learn to drive a truck you know
but i was 11. so i couldn't so no no no
lawsuits did anyone in your family ever
represent themselves in court
that you know my dad uh well the only i
i so i did have a little clarity on this
which is my dad lived in the apartment
he wasn't much of an earner he wasn't
very good financially or anything as
i've
discussed
um but at some point
when i was maybe in the
eighth grade or seventh grade he bought
a very small farmhouse an a-frame house
in deep north hollywood where it starts
getting a little dicey
and he bought it for like thirteen
thousand dollars and like okay
i was probably a little younger i don't
know like 1975. but it always bothered
me
that
he could even cobble together two
thousand dollars for a down payment and
and how did he even buy a house because
he was financially he didn't have a
credit card he just kind of lived
paycheck to paycheck he didn't have any
he didn't have any savvy or anything
that way and so uh way later when i was
like 40 i just said
dad you saving up the money going the
bank filling out the paperwork getting a
loan you know it just doesn't jive with
like who who you were what's the real
deal and he said yeah i was driving in
my vw bus and somebody
bug i should say at a vw someone
rear-ended him and the guy who was in
the car with him was like i got a friend
who's a lawyer
you should call somebody my dad was like
i don't know why you know and he said
god call the guy he ended up getting
like three grand from the insurance
company
and i love it that's what i love that's
the down payment for the house and now
it explains where he got a house right
so there was
you know not a not an illustrious long
legal career but
he got rear-ended at some point
i like how that's changed the trajectory
of your family is your dad your dad
getting rear-ended personally and that
guy knew a lawyer yeah that's great
hmm that's how old were you when you got
your passport
uh
uh
35 or something i i mean i remember
i never got a passport but maybe season
three of the man show i got to figure
out how how old i was but yeah i was 35
30 36 it was like season three of the
man show
and we were doing our end wrap around
best of whatever's and it was announced
that we're going to jamaica to shoot
these things
like i am and i was like all right and
then somebody said you need a passport
and i didn't have passports so i i went
i think i went and got one too so we
could go to jamaica i think
that mid-30s okay
that's [ __ ] wild have you been to a
circus in the last 365 days no
have you had funnel cake
no a corn dog or fried oreos in the last
365. no but now i want a poor dog
and i want to eat it at the circus uh
when was the last time you had lobster
man
uh
i it's been a it's a year i would say i
try to order it when other people are
paying if they're not going out i don't
know it's a true dirtbag and i love it
i love it i'll take the four pounder to
get out
did you guys celebrate christmas growing
up did we what celebrate christmas
kind of haphazard kind of way my my gran
we'd go to my grandmother's house on new
year's christmas eve i should say she
had a rubber tree and a potted plant
and she would decorate this rubber tree
because buying a christmas tree seemed
you know pretty pretty ostentatious my
christmas tree
no i mean not for my mom cut off a
branch from a pine tree
at least it sounds like it happened in
the depression the wall and we it sounds
like it's in black and white i mean i
want i you know i i think my dad you
know you could go to the parking lot of
lucky's and get like a three footer for
like eight bucks or something maybe once
but not not a traditional big thing to
get the tree decorated no we didn't get
so i was smart in that
or savvy or something i never had any
money my family didn't have money didn't
give it away or anything but i i still
wanted stuff i liked mechanical stuff
you know i like stuffed bmx bike parts
and stuff like that i was always
mechanical so at a certain point i just
said to everyone in the family
i'm just going to collect around
christmas time and you know i'd get 10
bucks for my grandparents i get 20 bucks
from my dad and get 10 bucks for my
stepdad i just collect i just make the
rounds collect it sure
you know put together 60 70 bucks and
then i'd celebrate by buying a forks for
a bmx bike or something like that but
damn that's that's how i crowdfunding
[ __ ] hearts
that is [ __ ] hardcore are you
currently in a beef with a neighbor
uh not since i moved to a kind of normal
neighborhood but when i used to live in
hollywood
and hollywood hills there was kind there
was many beefs with many neighbors i
could imagine you ruffled you know
ruffle and some feathers out there
um i'm so sort of go about my my
business but
there's a lot of crazy people in l.a and
i lived next to a lot of them yeah we
dealt with that we stayed in an airbnb
in the hollywood hills and we got in
trouble we got kicked out and yeah
really 36 hours something like that yeah
they're dicks yeah yeah and i moved to
uh la crescent
in the attic and it
people are normal there they're nice
okay
is your voice mailbox full
apparently maybe really i don't know i
never check it
how many unread emails do you have
8 000.
i don't know 16 000.
i don't know you could be a millionaire
whatever that amount whatever that
number is that's what i got
what are your thoughts on hawaiian pizza
i like it you do get a lot of [ __ ] okay
get it
i'm not defending it but it's good i'm
just saying i like it sure you know
people
judge
well first off it's generally i like
thin crust but it's generally thin crust
with canadian bacon and then there's
pineapple so basically you're just
saying you don't like pineapple or you
don't like it on your pizza but i like
it
but
i think the best is get the hawaiian
style and then get like a meat lovers or
something and then
go one slice then switch over to the
meat lovers and just get the olives or
the mushrooms just break it up so it's
all about the same bite a little savory
and sweet all right will you do bite for
bite like babe bite one and then bite
the other or eat one whole slice then
the other whole slice i'll take them
both i'll roll them both up
i'll shove one up my ass and i'll eat
the other no i'm not a maniac i don't
think i'm insane
eating disorder
[Laughter]
are you a biting sip guy do you take a
bite of something and take a sip or do
you do you eat it and then drink after
um
i would say i'm a bite and sip guy but
you know i'm not wed to that cadence
okay like sometimes i'll feel bold and
take two sips in a row and maybe only
one bite and then another time i'll
throw a curve ball and freak out
everyone at the table by taking two
bites and then one sip you know
okay unless someone notices and then
they're like hey bite chip by chip
brother you just did two sips what's up
ever been to colonial williamsburg no
ever owned a paintball gun
nah not owned one i've played it before
ever been to a civil war reenactment no
interesting i've written your name in
wet cement
um
now i'm trying yeah well i i poured a
slab in in my garage built a big garage
and i poured a slab and i put my kids
initials there you go in there but
that's about it that's just oh and i
think i gave him a handprint i think i
told him that's big that's right we got
our pool done we did that that's classy
play horseshoes
no i have but not not a big thing can
you play chess no not at all nothing
close i can't play piano or chess or
languages or any of the stuff that
people
the classical people yeah yeah
uh at any point were you really into
hacky sack no okay do you own a metal
detector no ever been magnet fishing
no but i would i i'm i'm intrigued oh i
love those videos
magnet fishing yeah jeffrey oh it's
great
i've never you always wanted to pull up
a bot like you know a gun pull
i thought they're feeding fish you know
a iron bait or something and then
it's like
fishing oh you're talking about fishing
like fishing for compliments not not an
actual rod and reel i mean a rod and a
reel but getting [ __ ] off the bottom of
the light yeah okay
a lot of mercury in those fish out there
magnet fishing [ __ ] pulling them up
uh do you sneak snacks into the movie
theater
uh
no i ha well i have sure i mean yeah i
mean you're still in turkey yeah when i
was a kid yeah for sure but now if you
if you took the kids to the movies no
you buy the snacks there yeah okay
you don't have a chain link fence around
your house do you i do chain link yeah
really yeah it's it's it's black let's
try to get a few points for a hammer
color chain link yeah little it's a
little nice
black you know
it's a
it's but the house is nice it's just the
property's big and it runs along a like
a common trail or something and it's
gotcha okay okay all right
i'd go dog-eared redwood if i had a
chance to do it all over again okay very
nice i don't even know what that is but
it sounds fancy it's a nice fence that's
a one by
you know six-footer
privacy fence yeah just dog-eared at the
top yeah right right usually a german
shepherd on the other side of it and
[ __ ] ready to rip you apart do you
have any pets now yeah what do you got i
have a bald eagle
what's his name he's with me
sam
where is he oh [ __ ] he got out god damn
it dude i thought you were serious for a
second
this guy's nuts he has a goddamn patriot
i don't know i was in alaska with my son
a year ago and there were bald eagles
constantly he's like circling overhead
and i said to my son
if you get [ __ ] on by a bald eagle
you'll be the next president of the
united states
and i like the stream that wasn't
kidding yeah
look it up
i have a 110 pound black lab named phil
it's just a big okay big lap i love that
all right
uh what kind of car you got what are you
whipping around in i would assume a
couple
well i have a lot of uh vintage race
cars nice i do a lot of a fair bit of
vintage racing so okay um
have paul newman race cars like whoa
newman i love his iced tea yeah yeah
um
i just drive around like a lincoln
navigator just nothing okay nothing
classy
yeah that's pretty good
ever been to a wedding and served
breakfast food
uh well i went to jimmy's wedding and he
had a really good buffet for breakfast
the the next morning okay they had bacon
in the bloody marys
that's a jimmy yeah all right what's up
what's your go-to drink if you're having
a beverage if you're out to dinner
um
i can
you know i went out last night i was
sitting with the guy who wrote the book
with uh mike lynch last night and i was
all fixing to get myself uh
a martini and then he ordered an old
fashion and i was like that looks good
okay so get out of the field a little
yeah so
i don't know if that makes me an
alcoholic but i'm sort of like sure i'm
a serial killer who will just prey on
anyone you know it's no real mo not like
oh
myself to teenage prostitutes like why
shrink your pool
i get it so i could have like a glass of
pinot i could have a ipa i could have a
martini or like i'm like oh it looks
good you have a do you have a wine
cellar at the house or like an area
where you keep wine no
i mean other than my belly
i uh i had a wine cellar in the house i
mean but there was no bathroom on the
first floor of the ground floor so i
blew it out and built the bathroom okay
in it so
i don't know what that says i mean i i
feel like it's more practical sure i
have a working bathroom well you can
keep a bottle of wine anywhere
you can't exactly [ __ ] in the entry hall
you know what i mean you have to think
of it that way
i assume you have a garage at the house
yes right
is there a refrigerator in that garage
yes what do you keep in there
it's not really for me it's like kind of
overflow for the for the house okay it's
not like oh i got the venison next to
the lucky lager you know it's not it's
not one of those i have
a shop that has cars and booze and good
stuff in the fridge and it's kind of
that's a little more of the fridge
you're talking about a separate property
yes damn it's pretty sweet yeah a couple
of bucks on this guy yeah not too shabby
that's a goddamn legend respect them
he's got another garage on another
property kev let's talk about dave dave
yeah not the bozo lives next door to you
no
i'm talking about when you're in a pinch
mm-hmm who do you go out to dave's got
your back there you've got your back
gang listen we've all had financial
problems oh yeah currently in one right
i'm tanking over here but we could all
use a little help say the check's not
coming till friday but you got the hot
date you're going out with the boys you
don't look like an idiot at a wedding or
something
you need money what now you do you can
reach out to dave or straighten you out
for a couple of days dave will break you
off dude sweet there you go
uh dave is a banking app that can help
you get up to 500 instantly with extra
cash that's more money to fill your bank
you can buy that wedding gift you can
catch up on bills you can go out boozing
that's what i would do
you can finally tackle those expenses
that have been stressing you out without
any hang-ups there's no interest and no
credit check needed that's dave baby
that's daisy and dave don't ask no
question dave's all right there's uh
millions of people have already
downloaded the dave app and get
financial relief when they need extra
cash so if you're in a pinch and need
some extra help download download dave
and think of it as helping a helping
hand from future you there you go this
is it baby download the dave app from
the app store right now that's d-a-v-e
sign up for an extra cash account and
get up to 500 dollars instantly
for terms and conditions go to dave.com
legal instant transfer fees apply
banking provided by evolve member fdic
future you will thank you
dave do it kevin let's talk about
movement movement baby
talk about a couple of guys in a
southern california apartment that
decided to turn the watch business
upside down new college dropouts at that
shout out to the dropout shop
doing it and gang sunglasses blue
blocker glasses everything you need this
company has it all and they have it at a
fraction of the price you wear a cool
watch that looks like a 4 500 watch
for a fraction of the cost
what are we doing you better believe it
uh that's how they grow into one of the
fastest growing watch brands shipping to
over a hundred and sixty countries
across the globe i don't even know it
was a hundred six yeah oh [ __ ] there's
only been about four or five of them
uh like not a big man has said uh
movement is expanded into blue light
glasses to protect your eyes from your
screens they have minimalistic jewelry
and uh styles essential that won't break
the bank all designed out of the
california headquarters there you go
shout out to the good old old cali
the blue light glasses they sent them to
me my my lady used them when she's
working the 95
on a computer all day helps hurts the
eyes you make you sleep better eye
strain the whole nine yards they got
your back got your back so uh if you
want to elevate your look with your
style that doesn't break the bank then
join movement mvmt and get 15 off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to mvmt.com garbage one more time
get a pen get a pencil pull out your
phone upload a browser do it mvmt.com
garbage now back that is yeah that's
what i [ __ ] like to hear let me ask
you this so you went to uh jimmy's
wedding can i ask you what you put in
the envelope
or how do you guys work that out
jesus christ um
i do not recall
i'm not good at that kind of stuff
i'm not that
cheap but i'm also not very thoughtful
so it kind of
it balances out you know like i would
have got you something really nice for
your birthday had i remembered okay so
i'm kind of back to even
um
jimmy
and then jimmy i've always been pretty
generous with because he's done so much
for sure you really kind of launched my
career and so you could
certainly justify giving that guy
something something pretty nice
um
that
being said i have no i have no [ __ ]
idea i can't remember if they registered
somewhere jimmy's probably like give to
this charity or something he's one of
those [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh hmm when was the last time you had a
massage
not that long ago but it was a thai
massage i don't know if that makes it
any better wasn't that relaxing that's
where someone's walking someone's
beating the [ __ ] out of you yeah yeah
yeah will you get a manicure and a
pedicure
i have
never
considered it until until recently and i
have had one
but uh i probably made it to my
55th birthday before before
participating okay
have you ever been on a tour of a
brewery or a factory like the pepsi
factory in atlanta um
the pepsi factories in atlanta i believe
so coca-cola's in atlanta that's the one
yeah coca-cola's in atlanta pepsi one in
philadelphia a way to do your research
that's it you're fired i'm sorry about
that i have been uh
i've been on a tour of the coors brewery
wow that's pretty sweet golden i mean to
give it some
uh
you know uh
context okay
i didn't
go to golden colorado to tour the
factory i was doing a show you know you
do shows all over the place
you got your saturday free you know you
roll in do your two shows on friday you
got all saturday around there's some guy
who works there he's a friend he's a fan
of the pot i can hook you up you know
next thing you know you're going down
there at noon it's cool had a good time
um
at a young blonde gal who was giving us
a private tour
and uh i said to her so what's the deal
with the smoking the bandit like why
couldn't they have
coors in texarkana and she's like what
i'm like smoking the bandit she's like i
don't know that that movie is i'm like
you don't know what's smoking the band
that he had he had an 18-wheeler full of
course that was the entire movie
so i was angry obviously immediately
ruins the door for him it did
she never [ __ ] smoked in the band it
was
so that was ruined 22. you're telling me
you never saw cannonball run what the
[ __ ] are we doing here and then i went
to the uh
i went to the coke i took i was doing a
zuna car race in uh it rode atlanta and
had an afternoon to kill
trying to think what happened we were
road atlanta i don't know maybe started
raining or something we went back and
then we took the the coca-cola tour so
okay i have taken i went to the uh
laurie seasoning salt plant tour and
eagle rock california
i don't think that's a thing
i think you broke into the factory i got
into that i was like in this fifth grade
we took a tour yeah i thought you went
recently you're like i had a show and
you know no
all right that's what you were doing in
fifth grade that's [ __ ] wild uh have
you ever left a bad yelp review
no okay you ever win anything on the
radio tickets or anything like that
um
no i i had i mean i used to work in
radio i've been there when they've you
know given away mountain bikes and
stuff like that
i don't know why but it reminds me of
something is funny
jimmy me and jimmy were at the morning
show at k rock for a while in los
angeles and
jimmy was
on the radio
talking smack about one of the guys name
was boogerman and
he was talking about yeah he was talking
about smack about boogerman and
boogerman heard it
and he came in to the radio station i
guess he had a key card or something and
uh
he
jimmy and i were in like the producer's
office or whatever just the two of us
and he
started to choke jimmy like right he
physically
he saw he was a crazy guy he was like a
homeless guy and he got onto the radio
but he but he was nuts and so he was
like physically
choking jimmy in the office and i was
just close to getting up
i just i figured i'd just let him
settle it you know and it got you know
broken up and whatever and and he never
got fired
but
he didn't get fired for trying to choke
a co-worker but boogerman got fired for
giving away a mountain bike to his
friend because he done the you know
caller 107. i got to get the mountain
bike and he had his friend call in and
rigged it and gave him the mountain bike
and when they found out about that
that's where they put their foot down
yeah they were always real sticklers
about that no friends or family can
[ __ ] participate yeah in the contest
i never uh
i never called uh i never called i never
won anything okay
all right do you fly first class
uh
if someone is paying you know like god
like back in the day if you do letterman
or something like that you get the full
first class treatment
usually if i'm paying
no but sometimes and then other times
there's you know the price you know i
just always go like how much is the
coach flight they go 400 bucks i go like
how much is first class i go 575 i go
i'm in i'll do it but then you get there
and you realize it's the same thing
you've got some weed thins and
everything else is the same yeah but
then there's there are times i i don't
know if they still do this domestically
but like first class was like four grand
and coach was like 389 or or something i
would never fight now yeah you would
never pump up not not if i was paying
okay all right i respect that you take
your shoes off on a plane
yes usually okay bring food on there
uh
no but i will kick my shoes off and then
go into the bathroom in my socks
what's that do for your
scoring system that's not good you just
broke it broke the scoring system
you wear a neck pillow
uh
i do not travel with one but i have 27
of them they just somehow forget to
bring them every time
do you and the family get away now what
do you guys do for vacations now where
would you go well now we're getting
divorced so it's a permanent vacation
okay but
and that should give me a couple points
right
but uh
we would go
we've been to hawaii a few times okay uh
you know brought the kids you know the
the kind of the kids thing sure how old
are the kids now if you don't mind 16
twins okay okay uh so nothing
you know nothing major but we we would
probably
probably got out to hawaii with him like
three times or something like that
gotcha good
uh since you brought are you moving out
of the house
are you guys gonna get rid of that house
uh
we will sell it eventually but not yet
nice all right
interesting you wear any cologne
um not not per se
i i have cologne i rarely dawn it
but sometimes if i don't shower for a
few days or something like that i'll
give it a shot before i leave the house
what's the deodorant that you're using
uh
i'll use whatever basically but i i like
toms of maine and i like the baby powder
i don't like the stuff that smells you
know that's like sport ultra red
you know whatever i don't i don't like
the stuff it's alcohol-based that smells
like deodorant gotcha because when you
get a whiff of a guy's deodorant you're
still getting a you know sure so it's
it's basically
if you ever walk into a bathroom that
somebody [ __ ] up and it smells of pine
and [ __ ]
it's kind of worse than just [ __ ]
it's like you know what happened in
there and i feel the same way about the
deodorant when you get the deodorant
that smells like deodorant you get a
whiff of it you're just getting a whiff
of that dude's pitch sure and it smells
altered all right so you go with
something like the baby like yeah i'm
not like a talcum baby powder kind of
guy sure or nothing really what about
soap what are you using using body wash
using a bar
nah i'm not a soap guy
i'm not a soap or shampoo
dude so you just rinse off yeah
basically
you're [ __ ] with us no that's that's
my thing i know it's not you don't use
any soap in the shower rarely
that's insane what
yeah it's not good for you
i'm telling you probably not yeah go
look at the studies yeah that's why
everyone's allergic to everything holy
[ __ ]
i don't have probably got a point i'm
the only person i know
that has no acid reflux no allergies
never taken my lun mylanta never taken a
tums never had heartburn has no
foodborne allergies can eat i did that
show hot ones i got up to the scoville
scale of like 35 million uh-huh i left
the place people are like how do you
feel and i'm like
feel exactly as i felt when i walked in
and they're like and they're like oh but
the next morning on the toilet man
you're gonna pay the price like i
couldn't even tell that i what i've
eaten or done i can eat any shellfish i
can eat any i can eat stuff that's
rotted i can eat stuff that if i got
cottage cheese and it's got green hair
on it i'll just spoon it off throw it
and i'll leave do you think this all
comes down to not using an irish spring
all roads i need to see the science on
this
well i will look i gotta say i know that
it does call it is linked to all that
[ __ ] i wanna say in my defense
i was never a funky smelling guy never
had okay some guys have it some guys
don't it's just like the floor and the
fauna you know some guys just have that
funk you know so there's certain things
and i never had that i was never like
funky b.o guy okay and so
also you know we didn't have a lot of
money and a lot of stuff and also i was
just never into personal hygiene or
taking care of myself or anything like
that
so i just like i'm just like rinse off
if i go
in the swimming pool that counts as a
bath to me i'll just get up dry off go
let's get up in the morning i take a
freezing cold shower for like 40 seconds
and then i'm i'm good you're good to go
yeah what about uh brushing your teeth
what's that do you brush your teeth i
don't know
yeah i do yeah i brush my teeth yeah
crest colgate what do you use the brand
we're talking uh i like i like toms
again because i just like i see where
you're going and i don't i don't want
the one with the flavor strips or the
orange you know line of goo running
through it i don't like the i don't like
sparkles i'm not a sunny d guy like
orange juice i don't like the
synthesized part of life i just went
plain spearmint white right up in the
middle done you know that's almost kind
of classy i know and like a weird like i
don't shower but when i do it's yeah
it's soap it's crazy yeah do you know
how to tie a tie
no no i i i've never
if i do a tie
uh
now the the wardrobe person has to do do
the tie
and then they always do it it's the
wardrobe chicks are always like 5'3 and
then they go i'll do it but they have to
do it on them
and then they do it and as they're doing
i go you're going to make it too short
because your foot shorter than me they
go no i got it and then they do it and
then they put it around my collar and
then they cinch it up and it i look like
you know like lauren hardy or one of the
bowery boys is going to a funeral
and it's like it's up there and i'm like
it's too short and they go oh yeah i
gotta make it longer i redo it and it's
like yeah that's what i was saying when
you're doing it i had uh
the only job i ever had
with a tie was i taught comedy traffic
school for a little while
in like
you know 89 90 or something like that
and that required a tie and i didn't i
had a girlfriend and i had one tie and
she just made this tie that's what i did
and i just uncinched it hooked it on the
doorknob on the doorknob and then uh the
next weekend just pull it over string it
up again but no i do not know how to
make a tie what's comedy traffic school
um people get a ticket
and they can go to traffic school back
in the day
like eight hour class and points reduced
get the points reduced even in the
beginning not even pay
for your citation so i would do if i got
a ticket i'd go to traffic school
because it was cheaper than the citation
you know and uh but get the points off
and then at some point they're like oh
you know it's eight hours it's super
boring so what if we did comedy traffic
school
or they did like pizza traffic school
and so instead of like 18 bucks at sears
traffic school
they charge
23 bucks and i would teach to class and
uh you know it's crazy eight hours
should feel like six and a half
that's pretty [ __ ] wild uh do you
know your uber rating
no i can't use uber i don't know how to
use it okay
how's the credit score
um
i don't know what it is it's it's not as
high as it as it should be considering
what i've
done financially right you'd be kind of
surprised like yeah you could go like i
bought
10 properties for 25 million dollars
sold bought bought sold paid millions in
taxes and some [ __ ] school teacher
and arlita has a higher score than me
because she
pays her credit card
all at the front of each month or
whatever it's not it it it kind of
punishes the righteous if you think
about it
ours are very bad it's good it's good
it's good enough but i i don't know
exactly what it is i'm 6 15. so don't
feel bad 6.99
huh
up from 5 20 like a year ago so i'm
doing pretty good what's the top is it
like eight or eight 50 i think i i
could be you know low sevens high six or
whatever it's respectable i like it
you're in the meaty part of the curve
that's all that matters uh what cards do
you use you have an american express
card
got a black one
really yeah that's the best the metal
one you've got yeah holy [ __ ] so you
could technically buy a house buy and
stop a bullet
that's i carry my breasts
it's over my heart at all times i don't
put it in my wallet no no i don't mind
getting shot in the ass
but if you wanted to you could walk over
the mercedes-benz dealership on the west
side and just buy a car and be at the
door
with that boom i i don't know
yes theoretically i don't know what the
i don't know what the limit is but yeah
jimmy got it for me like in like
1999 or something back they started boom
back when you could back when you could
get them the myth is that seinfeld got
it invented he said there should be a
card where you can just go spend
whatever and then they did it and
started giving them out to certain
people it's not really but i've tried it
at like 700 airport lounges and they
just can't get in yeah you're not
seinfeld
you're not jerry
yeah
but yeah i don't i don't know i mean i
don't know someone google it i i don't
know if there is i don't know yeah i
think it's limitless to an extent sweet
i mean i got all i need here what are
you sleeping
uh oh in or on in
um they could go naked or underpants
okay sometimes gym shorts no socks
um
i sometimes i'll start with socks kick
them off my feet get warm get them off
with your feet and leave them in the bed
no i have a valet
he's a nice guy he'll be summoned at
some point in the night
ringing the bell
or adolfo remove my ankle socks please
holy [ __ ]
um what else you got
never seen a crash at an air show
no
i haven't been to a lot of air shows but
if anyone ever pops up online i'm i'm in
any tattoos no
you want a fish tank
no never ever use a flowbee
no but i can't my style of hair won't
okay i
won't
gel with one of those do you have a
swiffer
yeah
do you own any fireworks any fireworks
at your house right now
probably probably for you around how do
you feel about seafood salad like the
fake crab meat no
not a not a seafood salad you ever used
the squeegee at a gas station to clean
anything else but the windshield
oh that's a very good question
yeah i've probably given a couple of
like french [ __ ] bass
with those things yeah under the pits
you know
no i've
i've washed the car like you know when
you have x amount of time you just kind
of keep going with it yeah
uh you know to be fair like spotting
seagull [ __ ] or something you know on
the hood or something like that but not
a full wash
i didn't detail it yeah yeah yeah i mean
100 garbage but i love it yeah i [ __ ]
absolutely love it the best the shower
thing
that [ __ ] blows my mind yeah i mean
you certainly don't smell at all you
look clean well the day is young
we can go out and
eat some cuban food and cuddle
afterwards and see how we feel about
that i mean stealing the turkey leg yeah
it's all checking that you've not been
able to read until fifth grade
what you think a year and a half it's
crazy yeah i i know it's been an
interesting journey you know what can i
say it's crazy gang the brand new book
that's out right now by mr adam carolla
is everything reminds me of something
advice answers but no apologies you can
get it at adamkarold.com adam thank you
so much for coming and share with us
anything you want the folks out there to
know other than what we said no go to am
crawling i'll do live shows there'll be
live dates up there too fantastic buddy
we really appreciate it what do you got
for him check out our live shows we
added new dates thanks for the support
we love you yeah we love you we'll see
you next week peace